le sénat a voté lors du budget 2010 9 à
l'article 13 bis une disposition
permettant de lutter contre la fraude
aux dividendes pourtant monsieur le
ministre
lorsque ce texte est revenu à
l'assemblée nationale vous l'avez
retoqué une mesure de recettes
importantes à un moment vous en cherchez
et qui évitait de taxer les classes
moyenne et mesure de justice auriez vous
l'amabilité monsieur le ministre de bien
vouloir nous dire pourquoi vous
n'écoutez jamais le sénat
surtout lorsqu'il est unanime dans sa
diversité pour vous répondre
la parole est au secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'action et les
comptes publics monsieur olivier dussopt
up
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je suis présent
avec vous
le sénat a adopté cet amendement comme
vous l'avez dit à l'unanimité et j'ai
souvenir avoir dit que nous pouvions
avoir un avis de sagesse sur sa
disposition tout en prévenant par avance
votre assemblée qu'un certain nombre
d'aspects techniques juridiques
communautaires liés à l'application de
conventions fiscales pouvaient être des
obstacles à une parfaite mise en oeuvre
du dispositif que vous poursuivez et
nous considérons comme en matière de
lutte contre la fraude fiscale
il est essentiel de mettre en place des
dispositifs qui soit efficace qui soit
utile et qui ne soit pas possible de
remettre en cause au risque de
fragiliser l'ensemble de l'édifice
l'objet que vous poursuivez l'objectif
poursuivi par le sénat et par
l'amendement que vous avez évoqué est un
objectif partagé par le gouvernement
de la même manière que nous continuerons
à travailler pour faire en sorte
d'atteindre le même objectif que celui
vous poursuivez mais je veux aussi
saisir monsieur le sénateur votre
question pour rappeler qu'il ya
maintenant quelques semaines à une très
large majorité tant à l'assemblée qu'au
sénat
nous avons adopté vous avez adopté
pardonnez moi une loi de lutte contre la
fraude fiscale qui permet de renforcer
notre arsenal qui permet d'augmenter de
multiplier les sanctions imposées à
celles et ceux qui frodent
qui nous permettra de rendre publique
l'identité des personnes morales
convaincus de fraude fiscale au nom du
principe brut anglo-saxon du name and
shame qui nous permettra aussi de
sanctionner les officines qui se livrent
à des conseil en optimisation qui
s'avère frauduleuse que nous ne pouvions
pas faire précédemment et de la même
manière parallèlement dans le projet de
loi de finances le gouvernement à
inscrire des crédits pour permettre à
l'administration de bercy puisqu'elle a
été cité dans quelques échos que j'ai pu
saisir à l'occasion de votre question
d'être mieux équipée d'être plus
performantes notamment en matière
d'analysé de données publiques afin de
prévenir et de mieux lutter contre la
fraude fiscale
cette question de la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale je crois nous rassemble
toutes et tous l'expression du sénat à
l'occasion du projet de la finance a été
convergente avec celle du gouvernement
sur le sujet nous avons à surmonter des
difficultés techniques et juridiques
et je ne doute pas que les scènes les
semaines qui viennent nous permettront
de le faire monsieur de lège sur le
ministre je ne suis pas surpris de votre
réponse
elle est digne de monsieur gilles
legendre qui considéraient que le
problème de la majorité c'est d'être
trop intelligent vous savez le ministre
même avec des moyens limités tout à
chacun les capable de comprendre que
dans votre réponse qui n'en est pas une
vous bottez en touche votre réponse et
l'illustrent parfaitement les limites du
en même temps c'est à dire un discours
et des actes qui n'ont strictement rien
à voir avec le discours sur le mini
c'est une période de voeux permettez moi
d'en adresser un atout le gouvernement
cesser de prendre les français et les
élus incapables de comprendre vos
mesurer vos discours vous n'avez pas le
monopole de l'intelligence c'est bien de
vouloir mettre en place des
consultations populaires
mais si elles doivent connaître le même
sort que notre dame des landes
c'est vraiment inutile
alors monsieur le ministre nous vous
avons alerté sur la fiscalité que l'on à
conclure nous vous avons alerté sur la
cg écoutez donc le sénat les
institutions la république et la france
s'en porteront mieux
[Applaudissements]
là